[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le mardi 7 décembre voici
les titres
la centrale de géothermie de
vélizy-villacoublay ton service a été
inauguré ce mardi matin par les
différents acteurs du projet désormais
l'équivalent de 12 mille foyers de la
ville vont pouvoir bénéficier de ce
procédé pour se chauffer avoir de l'eau
chaude du cyclisme pour améliorer la
santé physique et psychique des
résidents des pas de la fédération
française de cyclisme a lancé ce
dispositif en partenariat avec le
conseil départemental et 12 structures
yvelinoise en bénéficient notamment la
résidence des saules à guyancourt
et puis la ville de plaisir incite ses
habitants à planter des arbres
l'objectif créer des micro forêt urbaine
pour lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique samedi le coup d'envoi de
l'opération a été donné avec la
plantation de 1650 arbre un rendez-vous
aussi tout à l'heure et on reviendra
également un sur ces annonces dernières
annonces du gouvernement liée à la crise
sanitaire notamment celle du
renforcement du protocole sanitaire à
l'école primaire on en parle tout à
l'heure avec l'association de parents
d'élèves de l'apel montigny le
bretonneux
[Musique]
après plusieurs mois de travaux la
centrale de géothermie de
vélizy-villacoublay été mises en service
douze mille logements de la commune vont
pouvoir désormais se chauffer et grâce à
l'internet à la température des
sous-sols explications avec mélanie poké
à près de deux kilomètres sous terre ce
forage récupère de l'eau dans un
réservoir liens naturels capté à 65°
elle va ensuite permettre de chauffer
l'eau du chauffage urbain de la ville de
vélizy villacoublay sur le principe de
la géothermie on va chercher cette
chaleur de la terre consorts qui permet
de chauffer les réseaux et ensuite on
réinjecte on a toujours depuis un puits
de soutirage et un puits de réinjection
on réinjecte donc l'eau froide qui a
perdu ses calories puisque on la sort à
65 degrés et un arrêt injecte à peu près
à 20 degrés après deux ans de travaux la
centrale est aujourd'hui mise en service
douze mille logements en chauffage
collectif et entreprises de vélizy
villacoublay en sont aujourd'hui
bénéficiaire dès aujourd'hui les
billysiens ont gagné plusieurs centaines
d'euros sur leur facture de chauffage
puisqu'on passe au niveau du mégawatt
225 euros le mégawatt
hier à 93 euros aujourd'hui donc là et
c'est pas fini donc finalement on à
améliorer le cadre de vie ont la
meilleure la protection de notre planète
et en même temps
on améliore aussi le quotidien et là pas
de moi de tout les bisons
détenu à 80% par angie et 20 % par la
ville la centrale à bénéficier d'un
soutien financier de la région
ile-de-france et de l'ademe à hauteur de
9 millions coût total du projet 25
millions d'euros
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est également les
dernières annonces du gouvernement de ce
lundi le premier ministre jean castex et
olivier billand ministre de la santé ont
annoncé de nouvelles mesures pour
contrer la cinquième vague de qu'ovide
19è dose de rappel pour les plus de 65
ans sans rendez-vous limitation des
interactions sociales 2 à 3 jours de
télétravail dans les entreprises et vous
le voyez aussi les discothèques sont
concernés par ces nouvelles annonces
elles seront fermées à partir de
vendredi prochain et ce pour une durée
de quatre semaines le premier ministre a
promis que le secteur seraient
indemnisés dans les yvelines le pacha
club notamment à lucian est concerné
sollicité par notre rédaction son
directeur n'a pas encore réagi autre
mesure qui concerne les enfants la
vaccination sera ouverte aux 5 11 ans
sur la base du volontariat si possible
est d'ici la fin de l'année pour les
enfants à risques la campagne pourra
débuter dès le 15 décembre enfin à
l'école le protocole sanitaire est
réhaussée au niveau 3 dans les écoles
primaires en clair port du masque
obligatoire dans les cours d'école
limitation des sports de contact et
nouvelle organisation sur le temps de
cantine en lien avec les élus locaux
manuel afonso cancel est avec nous par
visioconférence bonsoir
vous êtes la présidente de l'ape et
montigny le bretonneux l'association de
parents d'élèves comment accueillez-vous
de manière générale ces annonces on va
rentrer dans le détail dans un instant
mais comment les parents ont-ils
accueilli ces annonces et de nouvelles
annonces du gouvernement alors l'accueil
a été assez mitigés il ya autant il ya
des personnes qui sont très contentes de
fait que fait que que l'isolément des
classes la nouvelle méthode d'isolement
permet de limiter des fermetures de
classes donc c'est vrai que ça libère du
temps pour pour les parents qui se
retrouvait souvent en difficulté
vis-à-vis de leur employeur à devoir
jongler avec leurs possibilités de congé
là le fait de passer à 1 k
positif enfants testés et du coup retour
en classe possible des présentations
d'un test homologué faire valider par
par les consignes de l'éducation
nationale possible c'est vrai que ça
soulage beaucoup les familles cependant
le retour du masque ne fait pas
l'unanimité surtout dans les cours
d'école bon en interne à l'intérieur des
établissements les enfants était
toujours maintenu avec le masque donc
tout allait bien
mais c'est vrai que beaucoup regrettent
enfants comme parents le retour du
masque dans les cours de récréation
justement et du côté des enfants à qui
l'on dit un coup enlever votre masque on
leur dit maintenant à nouveau de le
remettre dans les cours de récréation on
imagine que c'est difficile aussi de
faire passer ses messages auprès des
enfants alors pas si difficile que ça
les enfants sont de bonnes parties
comprennent quand même qu'on est dans
une situation
sanitaire particulière ça fait quand
même maintenant un an et demi qu'on leur
qu'on leur rabâche les oreilles avec ça
donc il s'adapte mais par contre la
déception elle est là elle est l ai
senti à les exprimer bon après les
consignes sur les consignes ils sont ils
sont bien éduqués parle aussi d'une
nouvelle organisation pour le temps de
cantine en lien justement avec les élus
locaux est ce que une nouvelle
organisation a d'ores et déjà été
décidés au niveau de montigny le
bretonneux
alors au niveau de montigny
l'organisation est ce elle se passe donc
auprès de nos élus locaux il ya eu une
présentation qui a été faite surtout
liée au centre de loisirs qui sont un
peu plus problématique
en règle générale là je peux vous parler
sur tout le territoire des yvelines on
déplore un manque d'harmonisation des
protocoles entre les services
périscolaires et scolaires les consignes
divergent ce qui entraîne un brassage
sur un temps où il ne devrait pas y en
avoir par exemple la mairie des essarts
le roi ce matin a publié une vidéo sur
facebook où ils demandent ouvertement
une harmonisation de ces protocoles
après sur montigny à proprement parler
les choses sont très bien gérés mis à
part le fait que les personnels de
l'animation périscolaire sont à flux
tendu
bas en soit les choses se passent
relativement bien
alors l'avancement des vacances
scolaires de noël de deux semaines
étaient aussi envisagés mais finalement
non retenu pour le moment puisque le
premier ministre jean castex a affirmé
que c'était une solution potentielle
y at il une crainte de ce point de vue
de voir une fermeture anticipée des
écoles et qui dit et fermetures
anticipées dit forcément nouvelle
organisation pour les pans pas tout à
fait la crainte elle est surtout liée au
fait que les parents peuvent s'organiser
dans l'urgence avec leur employeur avec
leurs obligations leurs impôts d'érable
qu'il faille prendre des mesures pour la
santé publique bon ça ça ça regarde le
gouvernement maintenant au d'un point de
vue des familles aujourd'hui on est bon
on fait beaucoup d'efforts mais
clairement changé à assise près de
l'échéance c'est c'est pas acceptable
une dernière question manuel afonso
cancel et c'est plus à la maman que je
pose la question au moins à la
présidente de cette association de
parents d'élèves sur la vaccination à
l'ouverture qui sera possible très
prochainement pour la vaccination des 5
11 ans est ce que c'est une bonne
mauvaise solution selon vous on rappelle
juste que les moins de 10 ans 1
représente en ce moment la classe d'âge
dont les contaminations au corona virus
progresse le plus vite est ce que c'est
une bonne ou une mauvaise solution selon
vous alors je tiens encore une fois à
faire le distinguo entre la maman et la
représentante des parents parce qu aux
yeux aux yeux de la fédération de
parents d'élèves on n'est pas une
autorité de santé on n'a pas à se
prononcer on n'a aucune légitimité pour
se prononcer sur ce sujet d'autant plus
que ça reste aux parents de décider en
son âme et conscience de ce qu'il veut
proposer à son enfant maintenant la
maman que je suis aujourd'hui émet des
doutes les adultes sont propres à
prendre leurs propres décisions en leur
âme et conscience les enfants bon bah
ils nous écoutent les consignes qu'on
leur donne je vous avoue que je suis
assez mitigé sur le sujet je sais pas
trop comment positionner je pense que
c'est une cas de beaucoup de familles
merci manuel afonso quand celle d'avoir
été avec no
mercy je rappelle président de l'apec
montigny le bretonneux on parle des
lycées à présent avec tout autre chose
la semaine dernière le lycée jean
rostand de mantes la jolie a connu
plusieurs scènes de violence entre
incendie volontaire et tirs de mortiers
deux jeunes de l'établissement ont été
interpellés ce week-end le point sur
cette affaire avec bixente mais rien
senti steban voici des vidéos prises
mardi 30 novembre dernier au lycée jean
rostand de mantes la ville
ces scènes choquantes de tirs de
mortiers se sont produites lors d'un
début de semaine très agitée au lycée le
lundi un conteneur avait été incendiée
le lendemain un véhicule utilisé pour un
atelier de mécanique avait pris feu pour
des raisons de sécurité les enseignantes
alors décidé de suspendre les cours
pendant l'évacuation organisé donc le
mardi en début d'après midi les lycéens
ont été ciblés par des tirs de mortiers
d'artifice dans les couloirs de
l'établissement ce qui a créé un vent de
panique on a donc formalisé ça on a on a
argumenté pour anne aux autorités
académiques pourquoi ont posé un droit
de retrait et ce qui nous a valu donc un
rendez vous avec ces mêmes autorités
académiques il ya eu un sentiment
d'insécurité qui s'est un peu développé
et les profs ont décidé de poser leur
droit de retrait décidée en urgence tout
d'abord une remise à niveau des
extincteurs incendie un demi poste
d'agde est l'équivalent d'un surveillant
supplémentaire et enfin une journée
banalisée pour discuter et entrevoir ce
qui pourrait être mise en place pour
l'avenir les enseignants espèrent des
mesures un peu plus approfondie on
aimerait bien en effet récupérer ce
poste de cpe et qu'on nous requalifier
notre astuce zep en fait qui a été
supprimé à quelques années et qui
donnait des moyens supplémentaires à
l'établissement qui faisait une équipe
soudée pérenne
là cette année pour donner un exemple
c'est presque plus d'un tiers des
personnels qui ont été qui sont nouveaux
en fait parce que plus de statut êtes
donc plus d'intérêt à rester à long
terme dans un établissement comme seul
comme le nôtre les corps ont repris
vendredi dernier avec un dispositif
spécial mis en place par la direction
notamment le renfort de forces de police
en cas de blocus quant aux tirs de
mortiers de lycéens âgés de 15 et 16 ans
ont été interpellés et présentés à un
juge pour enfants à versailles ce
dernier n'a pas encore rendu son verdict
les deux jeunes n'ayant jamais été
condamné avant cela elle les magistrats
suivent les réquisitions du parquet anti
terroriste mohamed lamine ab rosé bien
renvoyé devant les assises il
comparaîtra comme complice présumé dans
l'attentât de magnanville le 13 juin
2016 un couple de policiers jessica
schneider et jean baptiste salvin était
assassiné au couteau à leur domicile en
présence de leurs enfants trois ans le
terroriste abattu par les forces de
l'ordre se réclamait de l'état islamique
mohamed lamine ab rose est soupçonné
d'avoir été présent au moment des faits
son adn retrouvé sur les lieux du crime
lui clame son innocence l'homme de 28
ans a déjà été condamné en juin dernier
dans une autre affaire celle de la
tentative d'attentât aux bonbonnes de
gaz à paris en 2016 il a écopé de cinq
ans d'emprisonnement pour non
dénonciation de crime terroriste
[Musique]
des effets bénéfiques sur la santé
physique mais aussi psychique la
fédération française de cyclisme a lancé
le programme cyclisme santé à
destination des personnes en perte
d'autonomie c'est en partenariat avec le
conseil départemental des yvelines 12
structures du département bénéficie
comme à la maison de retraite les saules
à guyancourt mélanie poké avec la voix
de nicolas d'entrée
[Musique]
de 20 minutes aussi il ne recherche pas
la performance bien sûr pour ces quatre
résidants de la maison de retraite les
sauces et le dernier atelier vélo après
trois mois d'exercice c'est le vélo ça
me plaît tout le temps et tourne sans
arrêt c'est sans ceinture d'elle je me
suis dit il faut à tout prix faire du
sport alors voilà je suis là et je suis
devenu sportif ne pas me laisser aller
donc qui est
un booster intérieur qui se développe et
c'est vrai que quand on veut faire
quelque chose de bien on force un petit
peu les choses quoi 10 résidents de cet
établissement ont pu bénéficier du
programme cyclisme santé de la
fédération française de cyclisme deux
séances par semaine on a vu une
évolution au niveau du souffle et au
niveau du rythme de pédalage savoir
qu'en début de en début de cycle il y
avait une intensité qui était vraiment
modérer les résidents parcours est entre
2 et 4 km sur la séance et puis du coup
donc aujourd'hui c'était la dernière
séance le vélo c'est une activité où on
est porté c'est notre home attisant pour
les articulations donc pour les
résidences et c'est très sympa à
pratiquer voilà il ya aucune charge
aucune résistance imposés les ateliers
vélos sont soutenus par le département
des yvelines une première en france les
ateliers durent entre trois et six mois
c'est un pari mais junte à paris à la
fois osé mais d'autant plus utile dans
ces périodes on pourrait avoir tendance
à se replier sur soi donc l'objectif
c'est vraiment d'amener la salle de
sport nepad avec toutes les conditions
de sécurité technique et médical bien
entendu douze structures et 120
personnes âgées sont actuellement
concernés l'établissement guyancourt toi
envisage déjà de reproposer cette
activité une rencontre à présent dans ce
journal isabelle et stéphane sont en
couple depuis dix ans atteint de la
maladie de charcot marie stéphane vient
en fauteuil roulant comment se déroulent
leur vie de couple quelle difficulté
ont-ils rencontré l amour face au
handicap c'est un reportage de mathilde
aux francos avec la voix de célia gars
de 100 go depuis son enfance stéphane
est atteint de la maladie de charcot
marie complètement autonome il vivait
seul dans son appartement à maurepas
avant de faire la rencontre d'isabelle
ils se sont trouvés il y a dix ans via
facebook grâce à la page handisport je
regardais les gens qui aimait et j'ai vu
son nom quelqu'un a commencé à parler en
a sympathisé allers venues à big n puis
ensuite de weekend trois week-ends le
père et le grand frère d'isabelle étant
tous les deux des personnes en fauteuil
roulant l'handicap ne lui a jamais fait
peur
comme j'ai plusieurs personnes
handicapées dans la famille le handicap
me freiner quand j'ai montré une photo
de stéphane à mon papa il a day l'enfant
top 20 il est comme moi quoi donc il l'a
tout de suite accepté malgré le handicap
de stéphane la répartition des tâches
ménagères est bien établie chacun sait
ce qu'il doit faire en général c'est
celle d'une cuisine ouais c'est moi qui
fais lundi celle ci j'aime ça je fais
souvent le ménage parce que j'aime ça
aussi puissamment occupe qui ça fait du
physique aussi ça fait un peu de sport
puis ça tombe bien j'aime pas faire ça
ce que je peux pas faire là le fait et
puis en général je me débrouille assez
bien isabelle est remplaçante à la
mairie de maurepas pour aider les
personnes âgées stéphane lui vit de son
allocation handicapé les deux avouent
avoir déjà penser au mariage et à fonder
une famille mais financièrement ce
serait trop compliqué ça c'est difficile
parce que j'ai que l'âge en l'allocation
handicapé j'ai une maladie héréditaire
qui risquent de se transmettre qui
risquent de se transmettre donc si on a
un enfant qu'à ma maladie ça veut dire
des soins derrière
je sais pas hospitalisation mais au
moins ans entre tout ça c'est des frais
ll est pas pour l'instant n'est pas
appelée par la mairie donc en l'instant
ce sera assez chaud d'avoir un enfant en
tout cas les dés sont unanimes amour et
handicap sont compatibles c'est pas
parce qu'on est handicapé qu'on n'a pas
le droit à l'amour n'est rien du tout
quand deux êtres ce n ya rien il n'y a
pas d'interdît à rien donc voilà faut
pas faire en fonction de ce que les gens
pensent elle est handicapée dont vous y
trouve quelqu'un d'autre ou il a un
handicap et à rien au foot avec tout ça
c'est des conneries m'interdit capita
pas droit à ce à quoi la planter un
arbre pour chaque naissance c'est la
démarche lancée par la ville de plaisir
samedi dernier 250 habitants ont
participé au lancement de cette
opération
l'objectif lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique en multipliant
les micros forêt dans la commune au
total plus de 1650 rares arbres ont été
plantés céline charles et patrick
jacques de dixmude
inutile d'avoir la main verte ce samedi
à plaisir tout le monde était le
bienvenu pour planter un arbre dans le
cadre de l'opération une naissance un
arbre nous nous étions engagés à ce que
nous plantions un arbre par ans formé à
plaisir et donc voilà on est dans cette
démarche là qui est une démarche bien
sûr tournés vers les enfants mais vers
la nature et on a ouvert sa à l'ensemble
des plaisirs ouah c'est mon petit
dernier qu'insiste et pour venir voilà
après on est très fort et très balade en
forêt puis je pense qu'il a été bien
sensibilisés à l'école on est venu ici
ce matin pour planter des arbres pour la
nature et sensibiliser les enfants aux
justement à l'écologie développement
durable et respecter leur planète une
opération qui vise à créer des îlots de
fraîcheur favorisant l'augmentation de
la biodiversité avec 54% des espaces
verts la ville de plaisir compte sur ce
dispositif pour boiser ces coins de
nature en créant des micros fort et on
est en train de recréer un petit
écosystème d'une de forêts naturelles de
notre de la région des yvelines donc on
a été répertorié des essences des arbres
et arbustes qui vivent dans les forêts
naturelles de notre région
principalement forêt de sainte apolline
et dans la boucle de seine également de
quoi ravir les enfants déjà bien
sensibilisés à l'environnement
en creusant un trou est un art de dans
les graines dedans
ggd pas encore planté et âpre et après
mes bleus après ça a pu se faire à
mesure du temps quand on plante un arbre
on dit toujours qu'on s'en souvient
toute sa vie voilà c'est vraiment en
fait un acte tourner vers d'espérance en
fait planter un arbre c'est un acte
d'espérance tourné vers l'avenir à la
fin de la plantation chaque enfant a
reçu un diplôme de participation
d'autres zones seront déterminés au sein
de la ville pour de futures plantations
plus de 10 milliards devraient être
plantés à plaisir dans les années à
venir
un mot de sport avec cet essai le plus
beau de l'année chez les féminines selon
la ou en rugby la fédération
internationale a remis le prix ce lundi
à emilie boulard originaire de la seine
les bords de l'ariège l'a inscrit avec
le quinze de france féminin lors de la
victoire 53 0 face au pays de galles
c'était le 3 avril dernier à vannes où
vous l'avez vu une accélération qui est
à l'origine de l'action côté gauche un
habile travail collectif avant d'aplatir
le ballon sous la pression galloise
emilie boulard compte six sélections
avec les bleus 3 essais marqués bravo l
on se quitte sur ces images à quelques
jours des fêtes de fin d'année la féerie
de noël s'est emparée d'elle en cours ce
week-end la ville a lancé son programme
de danse d'animation nouvelles
illuminations concert marché noël du 17
au 19 décembre dimanche après un concert
des pompiers un spectacle mêlant jeu do
son et lumière a été proposé aux
habitants devant l'hôtel de ville le
spectacle a duré 30 minutes de quoi
ravir petits et grands environ 500
personnes étaient présentes de nouvelles
animations vont se dérouler dans les 15
prochains jours écouté ses propos
recueillis par michael et demi d'euros
pendant quinze jours une série
d'animations donc un peu partout pour
bien montrer que on honore ce moment
très important dans la culture française
qui est qui et le quai noël
on les trouve superbe cette année
vraiment super belle
agréable même s'il fait pas très chaud
mais ça réchauffe dans les cas c'est
bien qu'ils feraient le temps pour noël
on
reviendra aussi la semaine prochaine
pour les suivantes c1 mais pour
l'instant ça va très bien et pour
connaître la suite de ce programme dense
des festivités de noël elle encourt
rendez vous sur le site dédié de la
ville d'elancourt voilà c'est la fin de
ce journal merci de votre fidélité dans
un instant vous retrouverez célia gars
de son goût à la présentation du 7-8
culture et vous y découvrirez notamment
les prochaines dates à la fiche du
théâtre de sartrouville belle soirée
avec tv 78
[Musique]